hey what's going on it's bill burr
oh raspy voice billy uh
my voice is coming around here i gotta
have low energy
this is gonna be low energy no
confidence
bill burr on this podcast it's a
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast
and i dug on it i'm just checking in on
you this is going to be easy listening
bill
adult contemporary bill no i [ __ ] up
my voice
and um it's better
but uh yeah i did like nine podcasts
four episodes episode family and then
a couple other things and my voice was
just [ __ ] shot so um i just got to
watch the screaming and that type of
[ __ ] so i'm very
in a very medium voice here with my
little bottled water
my halls menthol lip this my throat coty
and i'm sure all you guys got some
[ __ ] witch's brew that i can [ __ ]
drink
to help me out here
um i'd like to wish uh a happy
championship
to all the los angeles dodger fans out
there
who uh waited a long long
long time to win
what number are they on i know this is
not what a [ __ ] nerd i am
i can actually name brooklyn dodgers 55
i know you guys think i'm looking i'll
[ __ ] sit here right now videotape
myself
i can go from 1946 to today
does it make me any money does it make
me a better person no it doesn't but it
makes me feel good
all right the bums finally won it in 55
the brooklyn dodgers then they moved in
they won it then it goes pirates yankees
yankees dodger
60 60 61 62 63
st louis 65 dodgers
they lost in 77-78 and i want to say
they lost
in the early 70s too i always i don't
know they won an 81
they won in 88.
and then they won in 2020. six i mean
those guys
were when i was growing up they were
just
in the world series and that's it
maybe they lost to the a's or something
like that i don't remember but like
tommy
lasorda was just the man my whole family
absolutely just i don't know we loved
the dodgers because we hated the yankees
and um 77-78 they played the yankees so
we were rooting them
for the dodgers to beat the yankees
because god knows the red sox back then
couldn't do it so
it was like we were rooting for a big
brother maybe you can beat up the bully
on the block
which they finally did in 1981
and um i also remember in 1980 when the
kansas city royals finally got past the
yankees
uh that was that's when it was [ __ ]
great man it was just everybody had
these crazy mustaches
every every all-star was doing a [ __ ]
uh aftershave lotion commercial
and um playing on astroturf and all of
that type of [ __ ] and all these great
managers tommy lester and earl weaver
uh chuck tanner sparky lyle i mean it
was just
it was awesome man baseball was [ __ ]
awesome back then i loved it
so anyways congratulations to them and
you also your los
angeles lakers so you got two titles
two titles uh you know most people are
having a bad covid year not not los
angeles sure the whole [ __ ] place is
burning down but they're they're winning
titles right and left
i don't know they got two football teams
so they got twice
the amount of chances to win uh a super
bowl so who knows
maybe they'll get one of those i will
tell you i watched a little bit of that
was it the rams
playing the bears this week and um
if they just they just out coached them
because i don't think that they the rams
were that much better but
i hope i'm talking about the right game
because i tape so many [ __ ] games
i'll tell you one game that i'm like
three quarters of the way through and i
don't even know who wins it
i'm more than that i got like four
minutes left in the game i'm watching
um uh one of my favorites gardner minchu
who literally looks like he should be
hanging out with ken stabler on the
redneck riviera if you ever wrote
ken stabler's autobiography which i
highly recommend
um you know there's a lot of hipsters
out there that kind of grow the mullet
and the stash or whatever but i believe
i that i believe gardner's mustache in
long hair i'm just like yeah this is
this this guy if he
if he wasn't playing football he'd be
doing something else and that's what the
[ __ ] he just
it fits him so i was watching him
against justin herbert
two great young quarterbacks just
there's like no defense in the [ __ ]
game
and every time you think the game is
over somebody else scores a [ __ ]
touchdown is right back in it and um i
actually asked
a buddy of mine because early in the
game
i forget who scored i want to say the
jaguars scored
to make it like 16 to 14
with like 30 seconds left and a half or
something and rather than just kicking
the [ __ ] extra point they go for the
two-point conversion
and i'm just sitting there going what
the [ __ ] is this this is like that
patrick was [ __ ] when he started pulling
the goalie with like 10 minutes left
eight minutes left what the [ __ ] are
they doing
why is going for that extra point in
leaving that point
what the [ __ ] is going on right this
makes no sense so they go for it and
they don't get it which of course gives
the other
san diego a lift um
then then they get the ball they go
three and out they go to they [ __ ] go
to punt it and then
uh jacksonville blocks it and then they
score a touchdown
then i think they went for the two-point
conversion again and then that time they
got it and it's just like
so why didn't you just kick two extra
points i get it at the end of the game
so
you know i'm a man about town i travel a
lot i do a bunch of shows
i meet people so i got a buddy of mine
uh works for one of these nfl franchises
so i text him i go what the [ __ ] is that
and he basically what he told me
is that first of all he doesn't like it
he doesn't think it makes any sense but
there's a bunch of people
working for nfl teams now that are into
that
analytics and moneyball [ __ ] and they're
trying to hold on to these hundred grand
a year jobs
so they compile all these [ __ ] stats
to try to convince coaches and owners
that
if they listen to them they'll increase
their chances of [ __ ] winning
even though if you know anything about
football it makes no [ __ ] sense
whatsoever
not saying i know anything about
football but i know people that know
about football
john [ __ ] madden and john madden
always says
you take the points he hated that [ __ ]
when people would go for it on fourth
down he goes kick the [ __ ] field goal
take the points
all of this shit's gonna add up um but
it's also a different game so
anyway um i also want to give a shout
out to dodger fans
because i know that they were so hurt
when the diabolical houston astros
cheated
a few years ago and i have to commend
all of them
how outraged they were that their boy
justin
tested positive for covid yet he still
played
um and i i the outrage you know because
he's literally has a disease that has
killed a couple hundred thousand people
and he still chose to play and it just
was really big of those dodger fans
to really take that guy to task the way
that they did because if i learned
anything
about dodger fans over the last few
years they want everything to be above
board
they are not about that kind of baseball
[Laughter]
uh that dude could have had [ __ ]
ebola no dodger fan was gonna [ __ ] he
was too much of an asset you know and
then i discovered in the seventh inning
i was positive
that's [ __ ] amazing because i'm gonna
go do stand up in the woods
they know if i'm positive or negative
before i go up on the stage to tell
[ __ ] jokes on a [ __ ] pig farm and
this guy's playing the world series they
don't figure it out to the seventh
inning
you can take that [ __ ] as the rock says
turn it up sideways and shove it up you
lion candy [ __ ] ass
unfucking believe i am so i i don't
blame the dodgers for doing what they
did okay but i am so
[ __ ] sick just as a patriots fan
of all of you two-faced [ __ ] [ __ ]
sitting there acting like you're a bunch
of cub scouts who don't like cheating
first of all most of you golf you guys
are some of the biggest liars and
cheaters out there with your mulligans
breakfast balls gimmies
[ __ ] dropping the ball hitting
somebody else's ball you [ __ ] [ __ ]
love it i love it and i'm one of the few
people that will openly say
i i i don't think the astros did not
deserve that championship they 100
deserved it
and [ __ ] the dodgers in 2017 with their
bloated [ __ ] payroll and all those
goddamn free agents
okay the same way the red sox and
yankees my own [ __ ] teams
okay in the early 2000s you're gonna
tell me that was competition
100 80 190 200 210 million dollar teams
going into town to play the [ __ ]
colorado rockies when you got
you you bought their best player
you know oh no by the way like three or
four guys are also on steroids get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
uh there's no santa claus people people
look for an advantage
okay and that's what it is and if you
want to sit there and act like
you know it's only cheating if your
team's on the bad end of it
i mean look at the los angeles lakers
they're all [ __ ] prancing around hey
we
we tied the boston celtics with
championships what about that mobbed up
ref that
openly admitted he [ __ ] sacramento out
of that series you got a championship
hey l.a doesn't care they're still
waving that flag they don't give a [ __ ]
that first one they got from the baa
they want they count that as an nba
title before the nba even existed
get the [ __ ] out of here seattle
seahawks half your [ __ ] legion of
doom test is positive for steroids
you [ __ ] coach pete carroll who had
to run out the back door at usc was
doing so much [ __ ] up [ __ ]
go [ __ ] yourself and congratulations on
your titles
all right it's a dirty filthy [ __ ]
game it's just like politics
all right i'm gonna tell you something
right now
if you're going for the brass ring at
some point along the way
you're gonna have to watch harvey
weinstein take a shower that's just how
it is
you know and if you don't want to live
that world then you gotta you gotta just
[ __ ]
you gotta open a little [ __ ] bakery
in your hometown and even then
somebody's gonna be [ __ ] you on the
yeast
something's good somebody's gonna be
doing some underhanded [ __ ] to you
absolutely
i can't imagine the amount of car
salesmen out there
that have called the patriots cheaters
hang on a second let me talk to my boss
and see what we can do for you today
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you probably
golf too you [ __ ]
um anyway sorry i had to make that point
all right because i'm not begrudging
anything and i was very very happy i
would have been happy for
either uh the devil rays
or the uh sorry they're not the devil
raised anymore the satan race
and the uh the dodgers i always love the
dodgers and i uh
i love that old stadium their colors the
whole [ __ ] thing i got a weird thing
with like national league teams like i
like teams that [ __ ] hate each other
because i'm an american league guy i
don't know if you knew that about me
you know that's a big [ __ ] over share
with me
i'm an american league guy huh now you
know that about me
what are you gonna do with that huh
you're gonna bring that up at a party
hey you know that freckled [ __ ] uh that
says all the [ __ ] jokes yeah he's an
american league guy no i like the uh
i like the cubs and the cardinals i like
the giants and the dodgers
i like the padres i like when they wear
those those brown and yellow and white
uniforms
like when they had gary templeton or a
young aussie smith
i like those things um
yeah i guess i've got to be honest with
you i i don't even yeah i think maybe
uh
i don't know what happened i kind of got
this zen thing with sports now
i'm trying to remember why i hated the
yankees
i just don't give a [ __ ] anymore
um you know i think it really is
i'm finally because i'm not working
on the road as a comedian i can actually
stay home and watch all these sports
and i think now that you know my teams
aren't in it the celtics were in it but
you know the red sox [ __ ] the bed this
year the [ __ ] patriots are having a
rough time
um
i don't know it's like i can just sort
of enjoy them and not be
dying on every pitch or [ __ ] because
i actually
i actually felt good for dodger fans
with that ninth inning that nobody got
on base
because there seems to be this unwritten
rule that if the sports guards are gonna
give you a championship
in the top of the ninth or the bottom of
the ninth whatever when your reliever's
going out there you're three outs away
there's some unwritten rule that the
first guy always gets on base
and then the tying run comes to the
plate and then you have to age
40 [ __ ] years and
um the dodgers did not do that to their
fans
they did not so there you go
here's to the covid dodgers the [ __ ]
roided up red sox and yankees and the
trash can banging [ __ ] astros
congratulations to all of you
god bless you all right and with that
what else can i talk about here um
i don't know i got nothing to talk about
i [ __ ] up my ears so bad you know my
ears ring a little bit from all these
years of loud music and playing drums
and [ __ ]
and i wasn't thinking i was out
pre-flighting
and this guy turned on his [ __ ] jet
engine i thought he was far enough away
and i kind of put my shoulder up to my
ear or whatever dude
like two nights later i just woke up in
the middle of the night with my [ __ ]
ear ringing and it just has not
stopped it went down it already still it
already
rang but now it just rings a little bit
louder
it's like i got a phone in my ear
[Laughter]
so it bothered me and then i just did
what i always did
i was just like you know what
christopher reeves fell off a horse
and could never move again i'm gonna
[ __ ] because my ears ringing a little
bit
i'll get used to it [ __ ] it i'm just you
know gonna obviously protect
i'm gonna start wearing earplugs out on
the tarmac
um but whatever you know that's life
you know you make a mistake you [ __ ]
pay for it and then you just go you know
somebody else has it worse than me what
am i gonna do sit here and mope around
you know i mean i gotta wear earplugs um
speaking of earplugs the [ __ ]
election's still going jesus [ __ ]
christ
um i already voted i already voted and i
tracked
my vote my wife did anyways to make sure
that they
air quote counted it so um
i don't know we'll see we'll see what
happens
we will see what happens
it's going to be a whole new world or
more of the same
um i will tell you this
hell will have no fury like a donald
trump
lame duck oh man i can't imagine
i will tell you this if he does not get
elected
and the the electoral votes of your
state went
to joe biden i suggest
before november 4th you pack up your
[ __ ] and move to a red state because
i think he is going to [ __ ] lay waste
he's like glenn close in fatal
attraction like
this guy is just the most
petty um
i don't know what but uh
i know what happened to my taxes when he
won the first time what the [ __ ] gonna
happen if he loses
there's people leaving this state
[ __ ] right and left everybody's
acting like it's the fires
i don't think it is man
beautiful state beautiful people and you
come out here they grab you by your
ankles tip you upside down and shake out
every [ __ ] nickel they can
you gotta pay for this weather they have
freckles um all right
what else what else did i want to talk
about
um i don't know that oh i watched too
[ __ ] amazing oh i already talked
about um
watching uh badlands with martin sheen
and city
spacek um
i i watched the other day after years of
people
asking me to watch this movie or telling
me i should watch the movie and for some
dumb reason thinking i had already seen
it
i i confused it with another movie that
i believe peter boyle stars in that took
place in cleveland
i confused the movies but it was the
friends of eddie coyle was
the movie i was confusing for this one
about some cleveland tough guy um
but i finally saw the friends of eddie
coyle and i cannot tell you
how much i enjoyed that movie robert
mitchum is one of my new favorite actors
of all time sorry i got the hiccups i
don't know why
um let's see here
stephen keats yeah stephen keats was
[ __ ] amazing in that
it's just it's just nothing but
character actors and there's one little
spoiler alert and this is only as far as
like where they
uh shot the movie you know it's shot in
boston
and at one point they go to a bruins
versus blackhawks game
and they're literally in the garden you
know the footage is like during a game i
don't know how they you know
back then leagues weren't that big
they're like yeah sure put us in a movie
we need all the help we can get
so they have footage of bobby orr when
his hair was long
1971 they're in between stanley cup
championships they wanted
70 and they won it in 72
and he's sitting up in the upper deck
where i used to sit when i would go to
games
um it really is like this priceless
uh piece of film
on one of the great sports arenas of all
time
and um i know that you know footage of
uh
games played there existed what i liked
about this was it was shot from the fans
perspective
um absolutely incredible and robert
mitchum is just amazing in it
uh check that one out if you can you can
get it on youtube
that's why i watch a lot of [ __ ] now i
just look it up just obscure [ __ ]
you know if netflix doesn't have it i'll
just go on and i'll
i'll watch it there but just an
incredible movie the cars the acting
the pacing of it and just the story and
this was sort of during that time
where there was all these young
directors and writers and everything
and they were just sort of like hey you
know
you know what happened before in movie
making was great but this is how we're
going to do it
and we're going to create the new
hollywood endings and the anti-heroes
and
um it's just an incredible incredible
movie directed by peter yates
and it's robert mitchum peter boyle
richard jordan
stephen keats everybody in it is just
[ __ ] amazing
um released on june 26 1973 old freckles
was
five years old do you know what kills me
that i was five years old and i probably
knew how to turn on a tv and i just
didn't know
to watch the boston bruins and i could
have watched [ __ ] bobby or that kills
me
like if i could go back in time
i'm not like tom cruise i wouldn't try
to kill adolf hitler
i would go back and i would try
i would just watch all the [ __ ]
sporting events i could possibly watch
um and keep my [ __ ] mouth shut if i
if i knew what was gonna happen you know
just watch people enjoy like i would
watch the beginning of the big red
machine
before they won in 74 and 75 i'd watch
those oakland a's win three in a row
i don't know if i could have watched
clemente he died when i was three but
that's what i would do
i would watch the pittsburgh steelers
get put together
i've watched that undefeated miami
dolphin team i've watched that laker
team that won 30-something games in a
row even though half the talent went to
the [ __ ] aba
uh that year um i'd watch the aba
the kentucky colonels i would watch that
[ __ ]
or the world football league any of that
[ __ ] the indianapolis racers with
[ __ ] wayne gretzky on it that's what
i would do
what would you do if you could go back
in time
that's what i do um
you know
you know what else you could do you
could go buy a bunch of [ __ ] muscle
cars at that point that were like five
years old like hemis and [ __ ] and
everybody's worried about gas guzzlers
you buy buy those things for a [ __ ]
song um
i actually follow these guys on on
instagram
they're called uh old rides
and what's amazing is that the cars that
you see
in the 70s when the big thing was to
jack up the back end so you could put
bigger tires on it so you get more
traction at the [ __ ] racetrack or
whatever the [ __ ] if you're doing like
drag
racing or some [ __ ] and you're seeing
him like
cutting out the wheel wells and [ __ ] and
doing all this stuff to like gtos and
[ __ ]
mustangs all this [ __ ] that they know
you're like you might want to keep that
all original
you know that nerd you're beating up in
in class someday he's going to be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] on wall street and want to
go rebuy his childhood
um all right what do we got here uh i
got some reads
a couple two three reads here my voice
is starting to bug me i gotta wrap this
up here all right
fight camp everybody uh fight camp
times monday morning podcast whatever
that means there's an ex
uh do you get bored with your workouts
if you're looking for something that
keeps you engaged motivated and
challenged
you've got to check out fight camp fight
camp brings the boxing gym to your
living room
oh this is amazing do they got like a
virtual mickey
you can't paint this guy rock uh this
guy's a wrecking machine uh the boxing
workout
has always been ranked as one of the
best ways to get in shape and it's
honestly one of the most fun ways
to combine cardio and strength training
it comes with all the gear you need
the best freestanding punching bag on
the market
great boxing gloves quick hand wraps and
their unique
quick hand wraps where they got like the
fisher price the stride right ones
they just put it's already wrapped um
quick hand wraps and they're unique
punch taking sensors that show you
real time progress and stats on any ios
device new to boxing their 12-week stata
program teaches you the fundamentals of
boxing while you get a great workout
every time
watch yourself reach new milestones and
compete on a leaderboard with thousands
of others
fight camp offers flexible financing for
as low as zero percent
apr and right now as a limited time
offer
you can try fight camp for 30 days
with their money back guarantee just go
to go to
joinedfightcamp.com that's right
try fight camp for 30 days and if you
don't love it they'll refund your money
train like a fighter and turn your sweat
into results
to try fight camp uh for 30 days just go
to jointfightcamp.comrr
join fightcamp.com there you go
rule number one about fight camp talk
about fight camp on the podcast all
right simply safe everybody
every 26 seconds there's a break-in in
this country
but with simply safe home security you
can protect your whole home around the
clock
it's serious lasting protection and all
it takes is a simple 30 minute setup
you'll even get a free security camera
when you protect your home today
uh more on that in a second um simply
safe is an award-winning
arsenal of sensors and security cameras
that blanket every inch of your home
you know what a friend of mine just had
her house or apartment broken into i'm
going to get her this
you'll know your home and family are
always safe you set up simply safe
yourself in a few minutes without any
tools or wiring no technician or sales
person has to step foot in your home
then simply safe will monitor your home
around the clock with security
professionals
who are there in case of an emergency to
immediately send help to your home
plus there's no contact no hidden fees
no contract
no hidden fees and no installation cost
it's why u.s news and world report
named simply safe best overall home
security of 2020
right now visit simply safe bur burr.com
and get a free security camera plus a
60-day risk free trial with any new
system order
there's nothing to lose go to
simplysafebird.com simply safe
s-m-a-s oh sorry s-i-m-p-l-e
ah no sorry jesus bill s-i-m-p-l-i
s-a-f-e burr.com simply with an i
instead of a y safeburr.com
all right lastly but not leastly all
form
all right if you've been listening to
this show for a while you've probably
heard me talk about
helix mattress um helix has left the
bedroom and started making sofas
they just launched a new company called
all form
and they are already making the best
sofas we've ever seen
so what makes all form sofas really cool
for starters it's the easiest way you
can customize a sofa using premium
materials in a fraction at a fraction of
the cost
of traditional storage you can pick your
fabric
and its spill stain and scratch
resistant the sofa color the color of
the legs sofa size and shape to make
sure it's perfect for you and your home
they've got arm chairs and love seats
all the way up to an eight seat
sectional so there's something for
everyone and you can always start small
and buy more seats later
later on if you want your all-form sofas
are also delivered directly to your home
with fast free shipping
in the past if you wanted to order a
sofa it could take weeks or even months
to arrive
and you would need someone to come and
assemble it in your home
all form takes just three to seven days
to arrive in your
mail and you can assemble it yourself in
a few minutes no tools needed
and if you're getting a sofa without
trying
and if getting a sofa without trying it
in a store sounds a little risky you
don't need to worry
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it gross
uh that's more than three months and if
you don't love it they'll pick it up for
free
and give you a full refund they even
offer a forever warranty
literally forever to find your perfect
sofa check out allform.comburr
and all form a-l-l-f-o-r-m
is offering 20 off all orders for
listeners at
all form.com
all right there you go
all right with that that is the podcast
for this thursday once again i know i
[ __ ] with you but congratulations to
the city of la that is amazing that you
won two titles
you know not only in the same year
within within a month
um and uh
tampa you guys had a great year too you
want a stanley cup and you won an
american league pennant
uh who knows maybe you'll be there next
year i don't [ __ ] know
that's it i'm trying to be positive here
right as my ears
are [ __ ] ringing like a [ __ ]
all right that's it
go [ __ ] yourselves i will talk to you
guys
on monday have a wonderful weekend have
a safe weekend
be brave let your inner voice come out
let your hearts
sing you know let people know who you
are
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast
for monday october 29th
2012. how's it going how are you
you know i said a really weird a really
weird [ __ ] thought
as i was sitting down here getting ready
to do this podcast looking at my new
mixer
i had to buy a new mixer by the way
there was one bad thing that happened to
me when i went to australia
was uh you know i had this piece of [ __ ]
mixer that i brought that was like you
know
99 bucks and i plugged it into the wall
and there was some sort of surge in the
[ __ ] thing died
as i told you last week so i finally had
to uh had to go out and buy a new one
does it sound any different
i don't know why i bought one that would
cost me twice as much money to do the
exact same [ __ ] podcast that nobody
ever bitched about
other than the fact that they say it's
never out on monday morning despite the
fact they explain every [ __ ] week
that it's my monday morning i do it on
monday morning
okay it's not about you it's about me
this is all about me
you understand me what do you
um anyway i had this really [ __ ] up
thought that i've been doing this
podcast
since like june or july of 2007.
every basically every monday
remember one year i took two weeks off
for christmas that was nice
back before this became a corporate
entity
um i uh
i just realized i got you know i keep
forgetting to hype our new podcast page
the uh all things comedy page why don't
you [ __ ] go to that every once in a
while
oh i'm the worst why do i drink before i
do these things whenever i do this it
never [ __ ] goes well let's stay on
track bill
stay on track okay you freckled [ __ ] all
right here we go
so i had this thought you know i
basically been doing this podcast every
monday since
june or july of 2007 right every [ __ ]
monday
i'm basically documenting every monday
of my [ __ ] life give or take
sometimes a tuesday is sunday whatever
all right don't split hairs with me i'm
not in the [ __ ] mood
and i was just wondering you know when
is going to be the last monday of my
life
one of these is going to be the it's
going to be the last monday
you know how far away is that monday you
start thinking about like you ever even
think about just about like dying
you know i know it's a monday you don't
need to hear this well [ __ ] you i'm
thinking about it
i mean hopefully it's going to be a long
ways off but what if i died tragically
you know one of those [ __ ] what's a
good tragic death
you know honey can you replace the light
over the garage
yeah it's been out for like the last two
weeks and i get out of the car
and i just hear things i don't know what
it is
i don't know if it's the leaves i don't
know if it's a bird or like
some sort of bugs all right i'll [ __ ]
change it
you don't have to yell right and then
you go out there after you add a couple
of beers
right you go up there on that [ __ ]
stepladder
that's supposed to be for your
mother-in-law so she can get up there
and get her [ __ ] favorite bull to
pour a goddamn
[ __ ] or uh cheerios into right you
grab that one instead
instead of dragging out the silver one
because you're [ __ ] lazy
and you take that little step ladder out
and you get all the way up to the top
and it's only three steps and you can't
quite reach it right so you [ __ ] get
on your little tippy toes
right you start reaching up for the
[ __ ] all of a sudden you hear that
rattling you look like that you pull a
nerve in your neck and there you go
[ __ ] reverse
lawn dark [ __ ] inverted like that
plane in that denzel movie where he's
like i'm sorry
i was drunk and my afro wasn't picked
out correctly
but did i or did i not land the [ __ ]
plane safely
that's what it's going to be 90 minutes
of that 90 minutes of that
all right yes but you were drunk yeah
but you're still alive
well that's not the point yeah it is go
[ __ ] yourself
dude you know [ __ ] mad i would be if
i landed a plane shit-faced and somebody
gave me a rough time about it
but why were you drunk i don't know
because it's [ __ ]
boring because after i take off i just
throw it on [ __ ] autopilot
and then i'm basically just sitting in
this [ __ ]
uncomfortable lazy boy that i cannot get
out of for the next
four to six hours
until i talk to some other douche bag
okay i flew in [ __ ] i flew i had
[ __ ] combat missions i'm used to
getting shot at and now i'm doing this
driving a [ __ ] bus
the 37 000 feet you think i'm not gonna
drink
when it came down to it that
[ __ ] was upside
down and i still landed it and you're
giving me [ __ ] you how much [ __ ]
money i saved you
right isn't that what it's gonna be
maybe an hour that's if i wrote that
movie that's what it would be
it would be the first 10 minutes is him
getting shit-faced
right the next [ __ ] five to seven
minutes is all the holy [ __ ] we're
upside down a bunch of fat cows hanging
from their [ __ ] seat belts
as the hero the movie's such a badass
his hat doesn't even come off right
and he's just slurring i got it i got it
right
and everybody's screaming like a bunch
of [ __ ]
and he's uh go [ __ ] yourselves right and
then he lands it
and when he lands and everybody
high-fives him and he's standing there
going hey thank you for flying [ __ ]
twa or whatever he takes a little flask
out
takes another hit slap some [ __ ]
stewardess on her ass and he gets off
the plane and then he falls down the
stairs
right that's the left that's the left
turn for the comedy
and then everybody starts breaking his
[ __ ] balls
that'll be the next two pages so what
are we up to now page 19.
all right so from page 19 to page 120
is going to be him screaming at all the
[ __ ] peons that are yelling at him
for being drunk
you know would you rather have me be
stoned sober and actually contemplate my
own [ __ ]
mortality
you know i would have ended up in the
[ __ ] goddamn lake
you know something you always like
believe the movie and then hollywood
always has to hollywood it up
did he really have to be completely
upside down like he was in the [ __ ]
blue angels i mean i guess those planes
they can actually do that [ __ ] but give
me a [ __ ] break
okay do you know how much work that's
going to be for the [ __ ]
the props people where every [ __ ]
take they got a [ __ ] clean coffee
and trail mix off the ceiling of this
[ __ ] plane
this fake half a [ __ ] plate oh gives
a [ __ ]
let's plow ahead at least you know we
actually
we're coming a long way though i i feel
the fact that denzel is a pilot and
there's no racial issue there it's just
that he's a drunk
that's great that's actually a good
thing and i'm not even being funny like
that's actually a good thing
because the second i saw it i was
expecting like my old joke
you know there was going to be some like
i ain't flying with that son of a [ __ ]
i thought it was going to be one of
those movies and it wasn't it was just
like he did a great thing but he was
drunk
now what do we do bill we've seen the
trailer
how long are you going to milk it we got
it you got to fill a [ __ ] hour
how about changing the topic once every
19 minutes all right
fine all right let's get back to talking
to my about my death or
is my f or is this podcast just going to
go on
way longer than it should
way past the time that it's [ __ ]
relevant
and [ __ ] all you [ __ ] who send me
emails that say stop being relevant the
day i started doing it all right
quit going for the easy jokes step up
your game if you're gonna be [ __ ]
mean
let's try to be creative you know where
i'm at i'm at
paul verzi that's my twitter handle
anyways yeah what if i go way too long
and i'm like 87 years old like
approaching like that bob hope age
sitting here wheezing you know with some
22 year old girl
works over the varicose veins in my
[ __ ] legs so i can just keep
podcasting
or i could go out classy i could go out
at about 59
right in 15 [ __ ] years i could go out
like johnny carson
actually if i went left at 59 i'd go out
like jay leno and then i would give to
my podcast to some other red-headed guy
and then come back and take it
so i'll go out like carson at about
65-66
and i'll that's how i'm gonna do it i'm
gonna wear a tuxedo and i'm gonna sit
here quietly
and uh i'll pay the greatest hits of the
podcast from the previous week because
i'm too [ __ ] lazy there's no [ __ ]
way i'm going through
what would that be 20 years of a podcast
it ain't happening
all right so you guys just get that out
of your heads there will be
no farewell show on this podcast
you know this podcast i've started like
[ __ ] four times because i swear to
god i'm still buzzing a little bit
so i can't even remember what the hell i
talked about um
i don't know did i talk about football
yet have i talked about it i don't give
a [ __ ]
i didn't talk about i talked about the
patriots right
did i oh gets a [ __ ] you know what i'm
just gonna go forward and if i feel like
i already talked about it
then then that's just what it's gonna be
you like that
i got a little philosophical there i got
a little hippie on you didn't i
um i didn't really talk about it last
week by the way uh
i can't even i i started to touch on it
but i was a little out of sorts
because my uh i didn't have my mixer on
my [ __ ] headphones last week so i was
just really just felt weird to just sit
there be talking
to a goddamn laptop top uh speaking of
which
i went to that ted.com just look up
robots and try to find the one where the
with this is this lady is sitting there
she's [ __ ] talking about
you know having robots around the house
you know what i mean and it's the
stupidest thing okay she first of all
she's horring it up for no particular
reason in the beginning i don't know why
she's wearing like these hooker boots
she's sitting there talking about robots
to a bunch of egghead nerds
and she's still gotta [ __ ] it up it's
like can't you just stand on the merit
of the [ __ ] speech that you wrote
do you really gotta get people's dicks
half full just so they'll keep listening
to you how [ __ ] insecure are you
you're talking about robots in the house
walking down the hallway hey what's up
[ __ ] high five and a goddamn robot
that right and you it's not like it's a
movie it's [ __ ] real
that's not compelling enough of a
subject you can't hold the audience's
interest
you still have to put on your
streetwalker boots
it's weird she has on streetwalker boots
but she has on a modest skirt
it comes down a little maybe because the
boots go up so [ __ ] high
you know what i mean i mean isn't that
basically rule if you're gonna wear the
[ __ ]
thigh-high boots you basically have to
have on a mini skirt
um by the way how great a holiday has
halloween become
it's just the [ __ ] greatest thing
ever you know what i mean it's just
girls just go out and dress like horse
even girls who aren't [ __ ] dress like
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] great
you know phenomenal i took me out to
lunch and there was some girl standing
there
and basically who's kid news something
david lee roth would have worn except it
was on a woman so it was [ __ ] great
[Laughter]
[Music]
it was just black and white striped
basically
spandex suit and then she was standing
there with these green pumps on
and then some sort of ears and evidently
that was a costume
i don't know what it was i'll tell you i
don't know what it was but i liked it
[ __ ] um
hey why you know i was sitting here the
other night last night
actually he says through the cloud of
alcohol
and i was on the sportsman's channel and
i was watching rednecks
shooting wild pigs from a helicopter
this was a sport i mean who's kid who
it's a [ __ ] skill
the pigs are running the helicopter is
moving but they fly the helicopter they
try to fly as close to the same speed
as the pig and it's just such a [ __ ]
joke after a while
that it's just like you just start
rooting for the pigs stupid ass [ __ ]
pig just stay under the trees he can't
see you
and they're just [ __ ] shooting one
goddamn pig after another and i'm
sitting there going like jesus christ
two [ __ ] pigs
has got to be 600 pounds worth of meat
you know kind of [ __ ] barbecue are
you having stop shooting these goddamn
wild boars
right and they keep cutting to the guy
going well one of the difficulties
when you're uh when you are in a
helicopter trying to shoot a pig is
trying to lead them how far are you
supposed to lead them it's basically the
scene from full metal jacket get some
get some
get some except it's pigs rather than
children in vietnam
and women you know so anyway so they cut
to the whole thing like and it's [ __ ]
hilarious the guy who's teaching you how
to do it is some retired
special forces guy he had this
australian accent and i'm just thinking
of all the [ __ ] [ __ ] that this guy's
done
you know what i mean it's almost like
seeing like a retired athlete
who you know at like the ground round
who like won a super bowl and there he
is in the [ __ ] corner booth
sitting there eating fish and chips you
know what i'm saying
and literally the hottest girl in the
place can walk over and just show him
his clam
her clam and he's not even gonna [ __ ]
bat an eye
you know why because he walked on the
moon
it's over he's been to outer space
this you can't get the guy's [ __ ]
heart rate going again so i'm [ __ ]
sitting there looking at
this special forces guy just going this
is this is
this is the end you know you're sneaking
around saddam's [ __ ] cabana
snapping necks you know
dressed like tom cruise at the beginning
of [ __ ] mission impossible doing all
that [ __ ]
and when it's over honorable discharge
where are you in the middle of [ __ ]
texas
teaching rednecks how to shoot [ __ ]
pigs from a helicopter
and the guys just sit and they go yeah
you know uh you don't got to leave them
that far
just basically if you aim just a little
in front of their nose
with how fast the helicopter's going
you're gonna get a body shot and with
the caliber bullet that you're shooting
it's gonna be a kill shot
ah jesus christ
i gotta get a divorce um
so anyways this is the great thing so
they cut to the [ __ ] guy
whose ranch they're basically hunting on
and he's sitting because i'm sitting
there going why are they killing all
these goddamn pigs
and this [ __ ] guy on the ranch is
just sitting there going like
he's like oh they're multiplying
uh it's they're they're they ate all the
grass in the front yard they ate the
grass in the backyard i mean they're
they're a plague
we have to we have to do this by
removing 400 pigs from the population
it's actually a good thing they kept
calling them a plague
they're a plague wild pigs are a [ __ ]
plague
you know that's the one thing like i'm
fascinated with stereotypical
conservative and liberal thought
you know people just sort of think one
way all the [ __ ] time
like the genius of conservative thought
is it holds people responsible for their
actions
you know what i mean you don't get to be
like well that's because my mom
left when i was a kid go [ __ ] yourself
you stab
someone you're going to jail you [ __ ]
all right
that's when it totally makes sense
right but
those guys like that the thing about
them is they have a complete inability
to ever step
outside themselves and see it from
another perspective
okay if 400 [ __ ]
wild boar on your property or a plague
what are seven
billion human beings what are we
classified as
i don't understand what you mean god
said go
forth and multiply go out and take a
[ __ ] in the [ __ ] ocean i mean and now
what do you
put all this here for us like that
[ __ ] thought
you know that no matter what you do
you're [ __ ] right
you just see [ __ ] they're just looking
out their own [ __ ] heads
maybe one thing if he said listen i get
it
they got a right to be here too but i
make my living off my [ __ ] ranch and
i can't have these
fat [ __ ] running around eating
everything that i'm growing
then i'd be like all right i see that
but to call him a [ __ ] plague
you know does that make any sense to you
guys
did i did i actually say it in a way
that made sense
after boozing all day once again cleo's
asleep on the floor
anyways let's get to some advertising
here for this week
oh jesus and i talked too [ __ ] long
i gotta enter the fight i gotta enter
the password who the hell told me to do
this
you gotta make sure your computer's
locked down for what
like i have the codes to launch the
[ __ ] missiles i was trying to say
launch the missiles there
um stamps.com everybody hey
do you like going to the post office
well keep going buddy
because that part of my life is over
because i have stamps.com everyone i
have the post office
in my house what do you mean literally
not literally stupid i mean i have all
the components i need that i never have
to go to the post office unless i
choose see now i'm in the driver's seat
a week ago
or whenever the hell i started doing
this a year ago whenever the hell it was
it wasn't my choice i had to go down
there they had me buy the short hairs
now i got them now i don't need them i
broke up with them they're calling me
wanting to get back together
okay ain't happening why because with
stamps.com you can buy
and print official us postage using your
own computer and printer
whenever you need it 24 7 or you can
sponge off your roommates i imagined
probably get annoying after a while
um no more wasting time at the post
office what a hassle
um it's written right there in the copy
what a hassle how old was the person who
wrote this
what a hassle man the pigs came down and
were hassling us at the protest
man um no need to lease an expensive
post
uh postage meter stamps.com offers more
features than a meter
at a fraction of the price plus
stamps.com customers receive special
discounts
on mailing and shipping you can't even
get at the post office i use stamps.com
to send all of my dvds
to the wonderful places that i perform
at um right now you want a special offer
use my last name bur
b-u-r-r no risk trial plus 110 bonus
includes a digital scale and up to 55
dollars free postage
all right they're just giving you 55
bucks basically don't wait go to
stamps.com before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in burr burr that
stamps.com enter burr
all right back to the podcast here
um so anyways as i was mentioning uh
traveling to australia i i can't
remember that i already talked about
this
that's the theme of this did i did i
already say this stop me if i repeated
this
um if you never traveled outside of the
country i'm talking to americans here
and stop rolling your eyes you [ __ ]
[ __ ] europeans all right
goddamn [ __ ] you trip over a [ __ ]
broomstick you fall into another country
over there
it's [ __ ] ridiculous literally you
can from england
there's like people who can swim to
france that's how [ __ ] close it is
literally swim to france before the
sharks get them doesn't make any sense
but they can do it that's how close it
is
it's like when the bruins used to play
the [ __ ] whalers
you could decide at five o'clock you
want to go to the game [ __ ] it
jump on the mass pike and you would you
know make a left and you were there
um australia is a great one to start
with
it really is first of all their
customers is great it's [ __ ] awesome
they just say hey how's it going get in
there you cook they tossle your hair
none of that 911 [ __ ] slap you on your
ass you're [ __ ] in there
you're in the country then everybody
speaks english already
and if you're from boston it's gonna
sound familiar because they basically
have a boston accent
they just stretch it out a little bit
more we say beer they say beer
we say blockbuster they say blockbuster
it's a terrible accent go [ __ ]
yourselves it's basically what it is
all right they're good people they're
fun people
and they like to boost and they don't
bring up our foreign policy
i don't know why but they don't so there
you go
there's my ringing endorsement for
australia
um oh you know what he did when i on the
way back
i actually uh you know that duty-free
[ __ ]
i don't even get it everybody goes
[ __ ] nuts when they go in there and
they got like chocolate bars the size of
a [ __ ]
log you'd throw in a fire
that toblerone they lit it was the size
of a [ __ ]
pillow and that one of those ones that
you just throw on the [ __ ] sofa to
dress it up but you couldn't put your
head on it it's useless
actually makes you hurt your neck even
more not one of those i mean one of
those i'm going to bed
right full-size [ __ ] pillow all right
okay i'm having
a different way they gotta [ __ ]
explain it to you all made out of
chocolate
right they got they took a picture of it
they had a [ __ ] it was johnny walker
blue
or johnny walker black this thing it was
the size you ever see those gas cans
they use in racing
like nascar where they just [ __ ]
tipped that thing up so it was like the
size of that i literally put my [ __ ]
ghost white hand next to it just to give
you a little bit of perspective how big
it was
and it was like i don't know i was like
like 200 bucks
i can't even i can't tell if it's a deal
or not because everything's gigantic and
it still costs a couple hundred bucks
so i'm walking through there and there's
all kinds of [ __ ] cologne
like 10 years worth of cologne perfumes
all kinds of booze so i finally say to
this
lady i go hey do you got any you got any
cigars
and she's like yeah we do you got to go
in here so i walk through this whole
[ __ ] little maze
into this back room and i walk in there
i go you got any cubans you got some
cuban cigars and they're like yeah
we don't have a problem with fidel
castro that's [ __ ] you guys
all right so i say cool so i go and i
buy a box of [ __ ] 25 of them
and it's cool man they got that the
actual like i bought cuban cigars before
but like two or three and they put them
in the little [ __ ] baggies here you
know
but this actually had the [ __ ] cigar
box with the little nail in it and [ __ ]
but what sucks is over there they have
like
they put these warning labels that are
just beyond
warning labels like the first one look
at a bump
bumper sticker as they say bumper
sticker
across the [ __ ] top of it
and it was a picture of a guy's
cancerous mouth
like lesions on his lips and like he had
all kinds of periodontal issues and
[ __ ]
rotted out teeth it's like i don't need
to see that
when i buy a case of beer they don't
show a picture of a [ __ ]
how do you say the cirrhosis liver
cirrhosis size
cirrhosis of the liver liver cirrhosis
scenes
whether they don't show me a [ __ ]
picture of that some fatty [ __ ] liver
they don't
so i actually had to go between the
lesser of two evils another one had like
literally the skull and bones with some
sort of like
not a graduated cylinder the one that
kind of looks like a beer mug but
there's no handle on it
all you nerds out there know what the
[ __ ] it is right um
they had that on there that was like the
best i could [ __ ] do
and i brought it back to the country and
i don't know i've kind of picked up a
cigar habit i have to break it so now i
got [ __ ]
i got 24 left and uh somebody said dude
you got to get a humidor you can't let
those things go
bad so now i bought a humidor so now
i'm a [ __ ] smoker i guess i can't
give in to this habit i just bought a
[ __ ] is it a humidor
is that what you call it they're
teaching me all the [ __ ] [ __ ] i was
supposed to put the scars in today
now that they seasoned it oh
geez what the [ __ ] wrong with me how
bored are you that you start smoking
cigars at 44.
what a dumb [ __ ] um
oh so i didn't get back to the the
[ __ ] the horror talking about the
robots
all right so she starts her speech right
not a [ __ ] just dressed like a [ __ ]
like she put on half of her halloween
costume and then oh wait a minute i have
to give a speech so she goes down there
and she's just like she actually
sounds what she's talking about is smart
but she doesn't sound that smart
so i don't know if some nerd wrote the
[ __ ] speech for and got like i don't
know
[ __ ] broke out in like hives right
before the speech so they sent her out
instead but she's just up there being
like you know when i was a little girl
i remember just seeing star wars and
seeing
c-3po going wouldn't that just be
awesome to have like a robot
and that's like two jaws that just to
like kind of talk to and like joke
around with
and she starts talking about how she
feels that robots
should be in the [ __ ] house because
she wants her own c-3po
am i saying that right am i pausing at
the wrong time i'm going to c-3po
c-3po c-3p oh
i don't know whatever that's such a
stupid [ __ ] movie it was one of the
most overrated
[ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] movies of
all time i would rather watch
muppets take manhattan i think that that
holds up better
because at least there's adult humor in
there you know
you know totally ripped off use the
force
joel olstein that [ __ ] squinny died
guy well you want a t-shirt jesus why
don't you have a t-shirt just think
about it it's gonna happen
he totally stole that whole vibe i don't
even know if that makes sense you know
furthermore i don't care
plowing ahead to this lady sitting that
lady sitting there talking about these
[ __ ] robots you got to watch the
video in about i don't know 10 11
minutes in i can't remember where the
[ __ ] it is
they cut to somebody shooting the [ __ ]
with a robot
and it looks like it's basically a head
coming out of a giant vcr
and he's like sitting there like and
it'd be like if you had a vcr with a
head coming out of it
but like a robot head like bolts for
eyes and [ __ ]
but it has like eyelashes for some
stupid reason like blinking
like it needs to blink right
and he's sitting at it like he's at his
desk like almost face to face with the
thing he's just like
hey [ __ ] r2d2 look what my girlfriend
bought me and he showed some sort of
[ __ ]
i don't know what the hell it's some
macho chain or a watch i can't remember
what the [ __ ] it was and then the
robot's just like
oh my god that's really interesting did
she
and it's moving its [ __ ] head
can i ask either this might be the
dumbest question ever or just painfully
obvious
why the [ __ ] would i need that
why would i need that
like why why wouldn't i just talk to my
friend
you know what i'm saying it was it's
like the baseball kid from way back in
the day remember that [ __ ] i talked
about it here in the podcast one of
these mondays
they used to have the baseball kid it's
called baseball kid the baseball kid if
baseball is what you want to do
baseball kid will pitch to you and it
was a cardboard cutout of a friend
basically that you don't have throwing a
[ __ ] baseball to you
you know it was basically for the kid
with no friends so now they've upgraded
it to the person who has no [ __ ]
friends
you know what's great is that i bet that
guy didn't even have a girlfriend i bet
he bought the watch for himself
and now he now part of the sickness is
he just
[ __ ] lies to this robot about this
life that he doesn't have and you know
once you start doing that
it's an inevitable it's an inevitability
it's a [ __ ] uh cirrhosis of the liver
that that guy's eventually gonna stick
his [ __ ] human dick in that robot
mouth and the second that [ __ ]
happens
that's it it's the end of the [ __ ]
human race i'll tell you right now
there's [ __ ] the scientists out there
[ __ ] robots right now
they're out there banging robots you
know
under the whole platform of [ __ ]
research
it's really scary like go go watch this
[ __ ] on ted.com they got another one
showing how we're fighting wars now
and like these guys sit in arizona they
go to basically go to work they go to
war
and then they come home after [ __ ]
blowing up some bad guys
or hopefully bad guys right and then
they [ __ ]
go and they sit down and hang out with
their kids
and they're sitting there talking about
how uh
you know now the bad guys are getting
the robots and blah blah
it's [ __ ] inevitable all those drones
they're basically eventual all the [ __ ]
they're using over there i think
eventually they're gonna use over here
you know in the future there'll be no
more skipping jury duty
the second you skip it you're gonna wake
up in the morning peek out the window
and there's gonna be a [ __ ] drone
just hovering there
you have seven minutes to get to court
or you will be vaporized it's gonna be
one of those [ __ ] things
is this the least interesting thing you
ever heard in your life i mean didn't i
just basically do
every science fiction movie has there
ever been a science fiction movie where
they predict something great that's what
i'm going to do
i'm going to be original here for once
in my [ __ ] life let's go the other
way
it's going to be a friendly drone it's
going to be outside the window
go back to sleep it's okay
we set your clothes to go down to the
jury duty
now we don't need you so you will be
vaporized
you will be vaporized that's the way to
do it
i think that that's that's going to be
the the that's going to be the funeral
in 2020. i think by 2020
we're going to know definitely where you
go when you die
and if it's anywhere other than here
people are just going to choose to tap
out you know it's going to be like
getting a vasectomy just getting
[ __ ] vaporized still an intense
[ __ ] procedure that
that needs a serious talking before you
do it
but you know hey you know i'm just
getting i need to change
you know like when people on the east
coast move to like minnesota or [ __ ]
san diego
just needed a change that's what's going
to happen people just going to get
vaporized here in the future it's
[ __ ] true
you know i know you guys are rolling
your eyes right now but you don't have
access to the information that i do
okay so please uh reserve your judgment
or whatever whatever temper your
judgment
don't be hasty with your judge whatever
that [ __ ] expression is
um all right you know what you know what
one of the dumbest things i [ __ ] did
in the 80s
is i never watched talking heads stop
making sense that concert movie
i finally for some [ __ ] reason sat
down and watched it why did i watch it
oh i know i
watched it because this there was this
song
that was in a lot of movies like risky
business in those coming
age movies all the movies that i saw
when i first got cable and first went to
the movies and uh
no i first went when i first got cable
and i went to the movies
oh geez and uh whenever there was a
party going on
and they wanted to show everybody going
nuts
like three or four of those movies
played this song
where there was like no lyrics the song
just went high
high high high high
and the whole [ __ ] place was going
nuts that's just a great song to sing
when you're drunk the whole house party
and i never knew what the song was
so it was just in my [ __ ] head going
what the [ __ ] was that song
they always played that song in that
song but oh yeah by yellow
on that oh yeah remember that which i
always felt someone should have done a
remix of me saying
oh jesus to that i would do it but then
i'd have some sort of [ __ ] copyright
infringement and because i have
advertising on here at some point some
point somebody's gonna try to
come at me and get a couple of nickels
right but anyway so i finally looked up
that song i just wrote
googled song hi hi hi hi hi hi that's
all i did
and then i looked it up found out it was
a talking head song called swamp
and then that led me to youtube and next
thing you know i'll stop making sense
and i watch just that clip of it just
watch that
that song go on youtube that's youtube
video of the week
talking heads stop making sense
swamp just watch how that [ __ ] thing
is shot
and go back and watch the beginning of
the concert how they come out
is one of the coolest [ __ ] things
i've seen and to think that there was
that quality of music going on
and the [ __ ] that i was [ __ ]
listening to
you know and i'm not saying it's all
[ __ ] i actually owe
appetite for destruction and apology
because i went back and actually that
was another one that i watched when they
were live at the [ __ ] ritz and i'm
like i'm an [ __ ]
i judge that album because i watch some
[ __ ] [ __ ] quiet riot video
whatever that's that's how you do comedy
you just you just speak in absolutes
then you piss people off if i it was
actually even-handed no one would
[ __ ] listen to this right
but anyways that's one of the dumbest
things i did in the 80s is uh i remember
when it came out and cisco and ebert
were were like freaking out saying this
is like the best
[ __ ] concert movie i've seen in a
decade and yadda yadda yadda and all
this type of [ __ ] and i was just like
because the only thing i knew was
burning down the house i'm like oh that
weird guy
with the white lines going through his
head on the road at the end of it
watch out um
all right delta curing breast cancer
bill i just got an
email from delta sky miles with my
monthly up
account update all the texts and links
were pink
thank christ that delta is finally
putting forth a serious effort towards
fighting breast cancer
yeah isn't it weird that you can
actually get angry at a [ __ ]
something so good underestimate
overexposure you know what that pink
[ __ ] is right now it's ben affleck when
he was dating
jennifer lopez remember that point
and then all of a sudden the red sox
were doing well and they'd be in the
playoffs and then he'd be sitting right
next to the dugout you're like oh my god
if i see this guy one more [ __ ] time
that's what like that that pink ribbon
[ __ ] is
[ __ ] unbelievable it's just it's just
you know
i got it i'm aware
you know who do i give to let's [ __ ]
cure it
okay let him let him get go all right
all right divorce law
[ __ ] army dude that's what this next
one's called
hey bill my name is johnny
and i'm an active active duty military
is that is that how you say it like he's
good police
i am active duty military uh i just
listened to your comments about divorce
laws and how the wife gets half of the
money and i felt compelled
to write you about my situation no i'm
saying whoever's making more money
whoever makes more money gets [ __ ] in
the divorce
because britney spears got [ __ ] all
right that's my point
and generally speaking the guy makes
more money which i'm not allowed to say
some reason i guess that's sexist but
women can [ __ ] about it all the time
how can you make money but if i actually
acknowledge it
it's just one of those deals i'm not
allowed to say well i can say it
but then i have to listen to people
[ __ ] at me um i currently serve in the
u.s army
i recently filed for divorce in north
cakalaka north carolina
from my wife because [ __ ] wasn't working
[Laughter]
[Music]
this guy's definitely military getting
right to the point
we were only married a year and a half
as soon as she walked out the door
i had to pay her 820 a month for a year
uh the army told me it was mandatory
so on top of paying her her that [ __ ]
i now have to cover my mortgage i have
served in afghanistan germany romania
and even stateside for this country
and because my ex-wife decided to walk
out
i was entitled to pay her 820
a month isn't that unbelievable
why is that you don't have any kids
she's an adult go get a [ __ ] job
anyways the whole time we were married
she didn't have a job well there you go
i provided everything paid the bills
took her to nice
places bought her a dog put a roof over
our heads
i guess what i'm trying to say is that i
support your cause to find justification
for this [ __ ]
um yeah the the two biggest things that
bug me
are are divorce settlements where the
person
who makes more money has to [ __ ] just
pay for the other person like they don't
have two arms or legs in [ __ ] brains
two arm two arms of legs that's yeah i
did just say that
that's bugging me and um
and all these past interference calls in
the nhl uh nh
the nfl jesus oh geez
um this is how bad the calls are on the
nfl or how
lopsided that [ __ ] is i'm watching the
patriots today
and even when we're on offense the
second as a flag in the secondary even
if i don't see the play
i just go oh give me a [ __ ] break
i thought i thought that that [ __ ]
corner that got three
uh past interference calls i thought one
of them
one of them the one way just you know
was literally yanking on his [ __ ]
jersey and other that when he's just
yanking on it a little bit that's
football
all right i know i've talked about it
too much anyways on top of having a
stressful job
i now go home and try to scrape up money
just to put
just to put gas in the tank of the car
but she's because she is taking money
that she hasn't done [ __ ] to earn i'm
paying for her apartment
so that she can get banged in it
probably and
i to get banged in it probably and live
a simple free life it's [ __ ]
uh well bill i hope to hear back from
you and i appreciate your work yeah it
is [ __ ] but you know what you got
off easy you only got a year of that
i just wish i was a judge and it'd just
be like hey lady uh
as far as i can tell you're healthy go
get a [ __ ] job
and i can see if she took a year off
from work and she's at home you know
washing your [ __ ] undies and that
type of thing and you gotta you gotta
support her until she gets a [ __ ] job
a couple two or three months
what a world what a world to live in
what do you do all day can somebody
somebody who listens to this has to be
in that situation
all right you don't have to leave your
name you don't have to leave your number
i just want to hear from you what is
that like
to just sit in a [ __ ] house that you
don't have to pay for
is it kind of scary because you got to
be like well what if he stops paying
then i'm out of my ass
what if he decides [ __ ] you i'm going to
jail he or she
you know do you ever just sit there and
just like not get up one day and just
just gonna sit in bed and eat fruit
loops all day why not i can do it
you know and then do you ever watch like
oprah and see people doing
[ __ ] with their lives and get that sort
of weird feeling in your head like hey
shouldn't i do something with my life
instead of [ __ ]
sucking the life out of another human
being
no honestly i would love to hear from
you what do you do all day
do you get enjoyment out of that going
to the mall walking around where
everybody else is at work and you're
just sitting there walking around
trying to find another pair of
horseshoes before you walk into a
cheesecake factory i'll just have a
salad
all right so you can attract another
dick in your life that can pay for
another couple of years
that's the game plan that's gonna get
you to the playoffs i don't think so
playoffs
you kidding me playoffs uh all right
skeletons in her facebook
hey billy boy i'm a big fan a new
listener thank you
i am in a little bit of a predicament
i got onto my laptop the other day when
i woke up around one in the afternoon i
worked the night shift
i look through my history and i see some
[ __ ] up conversations that my
girlfriend is having on facebook with
another guy
uh they were old emails but it was
obvious that she was
she's still thinking about this guy wait
a minute
i gotta go back and do the math on this
i got into the laptop the other day i
woke up around
one in the afternoon i worked the night
shift i looked through
my history and i see some [ __ ] up
conversations that my girlfriend is
having on facebook
with another guy wait a minute wait a
minute you're on your laptop
dude [ __ ] all this [ __ ] just be honest
you got a weird vibe off your girlfriend
or your [ __ ]
you don't trust you don't trust her or
you don't trust
people in general and you went on her
facebook account
isn't that what you did okay
now we're caught up here there were old
emails
but it's obvious that she's still
thinking about this guy how is it still
obvious if they're old emails if she
hasn't emailed the guy
since she got with you she
says the one that caught me was from
around two years ago
it said something about having a
sleepover with this guy
the only problem is that we were dating
at the time uh oh
then a few months later she emails him
again saying she misses him
what the [ __ ] i've been nothing but good
to this girl that doesn't mean [ __ ] dude
if her heart's with this other guy she
lives in my house doesn't pay bills
or even tries or even tries to keep food
in the house
i'm always the one keeping the house
straight i'm the one who does everything
i'm too nice a guy i guess everything i
say she freaks out and starts to cry and
[ __ ] i've been with her for almost three
years
i don't know what to do should i
confront her about the other guy i was
kind of snooping on her [ __ ] when i
found this stuff
there it is there it is
yeah dude you know what you know why
you're snooping
and you knew what you were going to find
that you didn't want to find you
probably had one eye closed because you
knew what you were going to find and you
found it
anyways he goes i mean don't get me
wrong she snooped on my facebook too
at times and caught me talking to other
girls
but all my life i've never been
unfaithful to her
and this kid that she used to know looks
like sloth from the goonies
[ __ ] up brother any advice would be
great yeah you guys what are you doing
you're just clinging to each other break
up
uh what
what are you doing all right first of
all i don't believe that you've never
been unfaithful to her
i don't believe that because it took
your [ __ ] two paragraphs to admit
that you actually went into her [ __ ]
facebook
so i i think if this email was another
two paragraphs to be like except there's
one time
when i let this girl blow me 12 [ __ ]
times
on seven different dates you know
um
i don't know first of all forget the
fact that she's [ __ ] around or or
whether or not she's [ __ ] around or
whether she has feelings with somebody
else
how can you be in a relationship with
somebody that every time you bring
something up
or want to talk about something heavy
she freaks out and cries about it she's
not an adult
you know she's a child she's acting like
a little kid
all right there's no reason to
[ __ ] cry when you're an adult
there's no reason to [ __ ] cry unless
somebody something tragic has happened
to somebody you love
other than that if i'm bringing up the
fact
that i feel like you know you haven't
done the dishes as many times if i've
done it lately
or uh you know
i go to bed earlier than you do and you
come into bed with your [ __ ] ipad and
it's lighting up the goddamn room like a
flying saucer is coming down
and you have a little consideration this
if you start crying during that
you're an [ __ ] all right you're a
[ __ ]
child
you know what you should do you should
just get a [ __ ] pacifier that's what
i would do
the next time you go to bring something
up she starts crying you just pull it
out and be like
and you wave it in her face and you just
throw it against the wall you go you
pick it up you [ __ ] baby
right right there you're not gonna have
to worry about what to do in the
relationship because it's gonna be
over um all right
plowing ahead what do we got here
anymore advertising amazon.com you know
what to do
you want to donate to this podcast and
then uh also be donating to the troops
which i have not sent them a check in
like two months i gotta send them a
fatty
whatever i've been on the road for
[ __ ] seven weeks i'm just being
honest i gotta send them
or else the [ __ ] piano is gonna fall
on my head
um just go to billboard.com click on the
podcast page click on the amazon link go
ahead and buy something if you wanna
and they'll kick me a little something
doesn't cost you anything extra and then
i kick something to the [ __ ] troops
which i'm overdue on doing which i'm
gonna do
all right gamefly.com you know you want
8 000 games at your your fingertips for
a 15 day free [ __ ] trial
go to www.danegamefly.com
bill burp baby no not baby
www www.gamefly.com bill burr
two weeks of video games and then you
got it and it's over
and your life is great all right from a
lady in the lab
i'm a lady in my late 20s i'm very lucky
because i'm happily married and i'm
getting a phd
at a large research institution my phd
is mostly paid for by the university in
exchange for working as a research
assistant under a professor in my
department
uh that sounds like the beginning of a
porno my tuition is greatly reduced and
i pay for my education with cash it's a
good deal
good for you see person before
this is the kind of girl you want to be
with right here although you kind of
seem like you got some issues too you
got to work out your own issues before
you deserve a lady
like this a lady in the lab
she's got that white coat and those
smart glasses
she looks like a nerd and one day you'd
take out your [ __ ]
she undoes her hair takes off the
glasses does that [ __ ] flip
and next thing you know you're having a
kid
that's called the lady in the lab love
song um here's my problem i work on a
large research team with several other
students one of whom is
a much older man i know this is going to
go into sexual direction at some point
is he some dirty pervert [ __ ] hair
coming out of his ears
um anyways he's probably in his late 50s
early 60s
i am regularly and why is he doing this
so late in life
because he probably has some fear
commitment i'm telling you he's taking
his dick out i'm calling it right now
paul versi moment he takes his [ __ ]
dick out
by the end of this story all right here
we go
i'm regularly assigned to work with him
and he always treats me like
uh like gum stuck to the bottom of his
shoe yeah he's breaking you down
his treatment of me varies from
impatient to cruel
but there's never any evidence of his
meanness
or an email trail of it he's too careful
for that oh all right i was wrong he's
just a mean son of a [ __ ] my method
for at least the last three years was to
kill him with kindness
it has never worked i tried to be
effusive i don't know what that means
and personable and sweet
but the only response i get from him is
disdain
i've given up on this method now because
it makes me feel like a doormat yeah
absolutely
and frankly i'm too angry i only speak
to him when i'm required to
and i've been trying to keep my head
down and graduate and get out
soon i will be moving on and out to
i'll be moving on and out of the
research team but i
but i hate to think about what my
replacement faces she's a lovely person
and she's already noted how mean this
guy is to me
and she's confided that he's been rude
to her too
i feel so angry that i can't help or
protect her in any way she even said to
me
i will just try to kill him with
kindness oh i'll just try to kill him
with kindness
hear her saying that broke my heart i
know it won't work
why can't you just say to the guy hey
just out of curiosity it's been i've
been with you for three years
and you you're one of the meanest human
beings i've ever met in my life is there
a reason for this
you know do i have halitosis do i remind
you of some woman that took you for all
you got in divorce court what exactly
is your problem you old [ __ ] leave out
the last part
um anyways she she says i don't want to
complain about him to any higher up in
our department
i'm certain no administrator would
listen to me or care
and i'd only make myself look like a
whiner
yeah i don't you you know what it is you
know why you've sat here for three years
taking [ __ ] from this guy because you're
putting no value on yourself
no one's gonna listen to me no one wants
to hear it they'll just think i'm a
whiner
um i think in a very nice way if you
haven't been a jerk to anybody
and you've been there for three years
you've never demonstrated any sort of
poor behavior why wouldn't they listen
to you
like that's old becky kill him with
karen kill him with kindness
oh my god if she's complaining
something's got to be wrong with this
guy right anyway she says and while i
know he's a bastard to all of
all of our other peers the younger
students and the secretary
he's a kiss ass to the director and
other tenured professors is this a real
person or a cartoon
this sounds like the [ __ ] [ __ ]
boyfriend of the hot chick in every
coming of age movie
you know the hot chick who eventually
ends up with the nerd which never
happens in real life
not until your 30s lodging a formal
complaint wouldn't resonate with anyone
who has the power to fix the situation
on the other hand i want to tell this
guy off or the very least
let him know that he can't bully people
like this he's a mean
fat miserable [ __ ] you really are angry
i love it
who has made my professional life hell
and i want him to know exactly what i
think of him how do you think i should
go about this without getting into
trouble uh by the way even though this
man has a semi-permanent position in our
department i still have more graduate
degrees than he does even though i'm
probably half his age
feels good um
all right you know what you're almost
graduating
you're saying you know this guy's a kiss
ass it's not gonna do anything i think
this calls for a good practical joke
just make his life a living hell i know
in the past i said don't [ __ ] with
somebody's car but this might be the
perfect time to do it
you know it's a good thing to do go to
mcdonald's this just this is what you do
you just make his life a living health
just go to mcdonald's
order some french fries and say hey can
i get a couple extra those ketchup packs
you know thank you and then you just go
out to his car
and you take the ketchup and you put it
underneath this door handle
[Laughter]
just little [ __ ] things like that and
then you just stand on the other side of
the parking lot
and you giggle as you watch this
miserable [ __ ]
walking over to the car can you please
do this and send a video so i can show
it
to all my listeners and listeners if you
have other just little
nothing where he gets hurt just little
messes that he has to keep cleaning up
you know just put a little bit of
ketchup underneath there
and i actually did that to someone one
time and i swear to god
by the time the person got to the car i
was in the exact same situation
was laughing so hard i almost passed out
just the anticipation of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know
who i was basically in the same
situation you were in you know
just do that it's it's [ __ ] hilarious
um and then the next time he goes out to
his car he's gonna
he's gonna have to like you know do it
with one finger to just see if there's
anything underneath it just do [ __ ] like
that
what else can you do i need to know more
about this guy
all right where does he live what does
he do
i would even go old school now he
probably know the the
the you take a [ __ ] in a bag ring the
doorbell you light it on fire and then
the guy comes out and stomps it out and
steps on [ __ ]
that's one of the oldest ones in the
book i would just do do
silly
i would just do silly [ __ ] like that to
him just something that's gonna make you
laugh get it on video
and send it to me we'll put it up on the
[ __ ] internet
but then you'll get in trouble i don't
know dude i don't know what to tell you
if you're not going to go to your higher
ups or confront this guy
i don't know how other way you're going
to get this person back
other than to just do little [ __ ]
silly things like that i don't know i
feel like i let you down
but you kind of walled me off
why don't you take off your smart
glasses and undo the [ __ ] bar right
in your hair
shake it out and just be like can i have
a word with you
you know talk to the higher ups like
that
use the power of sex i'm the [ __ ]
worst why do you guys ask me advice
is it because you want me to realize how
dumb i am because if that's the if
that's the end game here it's working
uh bill how to find a chick like nia ah
isn't that nice hi bill i was listening
to some of your podcasts with nia and it
just hit me
how much both of you are so [ __ ]
aware of what's going on
underneath whatever the [ __ ] you are
rambling on about at the moment
know what i mean uh sort of
she knows what you talk she knows when
you're talking out your ass or acting
like an idiot and she plays with it she
seems to understand
just like you understand that when
someone says
[ __ ] ain't [ __ ] it probably just
means that the guy is afraid of
commitment
oh okay i see what you're saying he goes
i'm talking about the
green room the green room episode where
you get in an argument with that lady
and you quickly talk about that um
anyway [ __ ] that seems so [ __ ]
obvious to some
especially comedians uh yet it never
yet never even considered by the
majority of people um no that's not
really a comedian thing that's just i
took a psychology class
i would really wish i could take credit
for the fact that i can make fun of
somebody's big head
that i somehow understand their
childhood now that's like psych 101 but
i'll take the credit if you'll give it
to me
anyways my question is how the [ __ ] do
you meet a girl like that i'm 29 and
although i know i'm still young
i can't figure out how the [ __ ] to meet
someone who's not some other clueless
[ __ ]
[ __ ] waiting for some douchebag to make
them feel better about them jesus
okay um before i even go through the
rest of that tirade
dude you know what is you keep
[ __ ] dropping anchor in the same
poison pond
all right you keep fishing in the same
watering hole you keep making meeting
the same [ __ ] girl
i'm not gonna lie to you it took a while
to meet a girl like nia but like uh
you know i did keep meeting the same
types of women over and over and over
and over and over again because i kept
going to like meat market bars
where would i always meet women i me i
always met women at the gym you know
i don't know how i always say how i
always
i always had game at the gym and i
sucked
i sucked in the meat market i was the
[ __ ] worst
the the the few times i try to go to the
dance club
nobody wants a [ __ ] pasty freckled
face
jackass screaming over usher in their
ear they just don't want it
they don't want i didn't have any
[ __ ] luck over that but you get me in
a goddamn
gym and you got survivor on the [ __ ]
goddamn uh speaker i i got a little game
not a lot but i got a little
the gym you know the gym is a great
place to meet a psycho
you know what i mean either somebody who
has unbelievable body issues
or then you get the married chick who's
who's [ __ ]
not happy in a relationship you know
she's going to the gym dressed in these
ridiculous [ __ ] outfits
you know those [ __ ] hoary outfits are
like do you really need to have that
much [ __ ] that little clothing on
you know uh they're always doing those
bend over you know those [ __ ] chicks
that actually go in the weight room but
don't really lift
weights you know they're always working
on their [ __ ]
hamstrings or whatever i don't know i'm
sure there's the guy version of that but
i don't pay attention to it
right the big creepy guy walking around
with this [ __ ] half a ball hanging
out
hanging around the [ __ ] i was gonna
say lunch room there's no lunch from
there is there
i guess there always is that little area
with the [ __ ] power bars
um it's funny they actually did a story
on the local news out here about how
those energy drinks
that they have actually have
surprisingly
if not dangerously high levels of
caffeine
isn't that a stunner can you believe
that
isn't that unbelievable that you could
sit there and be like oh my god i need
10 hours of sleep
take a [ __ ] drink of this [ __ ] and be
like oh no wait a minute i think i'll go
paint the house
you know you don't think that there's
something in there if it's not caffeine
it's basically liquid coke
you know i uh you know i know somebody
who
i i'm convinced they were [ __ ]
overweight but i'm convinced
that uh um it's not it's not who you're
thinking it's somebody outside of the
[ __ ] comedy world
was drinking those [ __ ] five-hour
energy things from what i heard
like they were going out of style those
[ __ ] things are crazy
can i actually say that they're
allegedly they're allegedly crazy
crazy they're [ __ ] crazy for feeling
so lonely um i think that's the podcast
for this week everybody
i gradually sobered up gradually worked
off the buzz
i hope you enjoyed it as much as i did
um
the [ __ ] you know what's funny about
the jets the jets don't try
against anybody in the afc east unless
they're playing the patriots
when they play the patriots they just
[ __ ] show up anytime i see him play
the dolphins
they're just like yeah it's just the
dolphins
[ __ ] it who's this the bills uh
get over here you [ __ ] knucklehead
maybe that's just me
probably is right was there anything
else that i wanted to talk about
hey can anybody explain to me how a
[ __ ] king snake can [ __ ] eat a
rattlesnake when the rattlesnake clearly
looks like it's biting it evidently it
has some sort of like
a little bit of immunity to the poison
unless it gets bit in the [ __ ] head
but then i went on youtube and i was
looking i was trying to find
a sanctioned loss between a king snake
and a [ __ ] rattlesnake do you believe
the level of free time i have in my life
that this is something that i actually
do i imagine a lot of you guys do it too
um all right youtube king snake there's
a sick one of like a cottonmouth
eating a [ __ ]
you know i always root for the animals
that's dying and i hate [ __ ] snakes
when i see one snake attack another
snake i actually start to feel bad for
the snake that's dying
doesn't make any oh kingby john belushi
you guys ever see this did you guys ever
see that that clip from snl
how [ __ ] tight is the band that's
playing with them that drummer is insane
on that i can't does anybody know who
the drummer is on it's an snl one
oh bill who gives a [ __ ] all right
that's the podcast for this week listen
listen to me i'm going to be in uh new
orleans
listen to this [ __ ] this is my weekend
i'm going to be in new orleans this
weekend at a casino let me see if i can
get you the
actual shows
harris in new uh new orleans
paris casino in new orleans louisiana
i got two shows friday night
showtime 7 p.m and 9 00 p.m and i'm
gonna be with new jersey's own
paul dude i called it versi
it's gonna be great it's gonna be great
oh by the way just to warn you i shaved
my beard off
just i'm gonna be i'm gonna look like i
did when i did let it go except not as
[ __ ] booze headed
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so friday night i'm doing that show and
then
saturday as they say in boston
saturday say are you really bostonian if
you don't even
it's just all vowels between the s and
the y
why don't you come over come over and
say
um saturday i am going to the [ __ ]
lsu alabama
[ __ ] sec football game that was one
of my bucket lists i said one of these
days i'm go one of these days
i'm going to what that l uh to an lsu
home game and it's finally happening
this is my little bucket list thing
so if this is my last monday know
that i died doing what i wanted to do
um you know what's funny is i actually
do die between this monday and another
monday do you understand the amount of
douchebags
who believe in wizardry and all that's
gonna be like do you know why he died
he died because he said he was gonna die
really then all i have to say is this
time next week
i will be worth a hundred million
dollars
no see that doesn't work because that's
something good
i'll go [ __ ] yourself and um
and then on sunday i'm just [ __ ]
hanging around
i'm not doing nothing other than going
down bourbon street
getting drunk seeing some titties and
trying not to get stabbed
okay because that's what bourbon street
bourbon street basically when you get on
bourbon street you stay on bourbon
street
do not make a right do not make a left
do not pass go
you stay on bourbon street on bourbon
street you are within the herd
you make a right or you make a left and
you are that lonely zebra
drinking at the watering hole out on the
[ __ ] serengeti and there's
something's going to reach up and grab
you
and they're going to find you know your
foot's going to be used in some sort of
voodoo [ __ ]
ceremony all right and that's new
orleans
that's new orleans stay on bourbon
street
oh tourist friends of mine um
and i'm hanging around why because
monday
i'm going to the monday i'm such a
douche i'm going to uh the saints eagles
game
on monday night see that's what i'm
doing all you guys who got married had
kids and god i gotta go buy a new rake
why'd you do it i know cause it's
awesome right
you get to dress them up this time of
year where you going i want to go out is
this
all right we'll get you a little [ __ ]
mask
do you know i haven't made my punking
bread yet cleo
cleo what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
you've been itching like a goddamn
maniac
do i have to give you a bath does
anybody know
the dogs how are you i love you too
the dogs like i know they don't my dog
does not like getting a bath
but do do they feel better after a bath
i can't tell if it's flipping out
because it feels good or it's absolutely
ecstatic
that it's over this dog goes absolutely
ballistic the second it's over you dry
it off and then it just sits there
it's almost like it literally has a
[ __ ] smile on its face
that's my dog um all right so that's the
podcast this week
youtube videos of the week once again
are we'll have the links to them
um is that that ted robot video
the talking head swamp hi hi hi hi
hi [ __ ] clip from stop making sense
swamp
and uh and please give that woman just
some [ __ ] practical joke [ __ ] she can
do why don't you just go old school
and literally put a bucket of water over
a door and just get him totally like
three stooges style
you know is there a way to make somebody
you can't make them fall down the stairs
that's bad
wouldn't it be great if you did all
right that's the podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves i'll talk to you next week
um my condolences to the ryan family
the one on the jets and the cowboys i
still can't believe the [ __ ] giants
won that game those [ __ ]
goddamn lucky [ __ ] great football team
but jesus what is it when is their luck
gonna run out
touchdown wait a minute after further
review
unbelievable what was it like just the
side of his pinky was out of bounds
unfucking believable when is tony romo
gonna have some luck
all right that's it see you
you